now let me back up if you've ever
watched a fail video of some kind
hey your tires are mounted backwards
hopping off or quickly getting out of
the way instead of being crushed by it
as it rolls over
i hate this one i hate even knowing this
is in here and i don't know if i can
follow
the rules but i still found it
interesting because it is the opposite
of what i do
pretty cool huh do you think your manual
is boring
that you can't learn anything from it
you think they make these things just
for fun
there's actually some pretty good stuff
in here okay if you got nothing better
to do with your life you can sit here
and read through the whole thing
that's a boatload of fun right well i'm
not going to say i sat here and did that
but i did spend quite a bit of time
recently because i was going through and
came across something that i thought was
kind of cool answered a question from a
long time ago so then i got to looking
and i found all sorts of other pretty
cool stuff in there too
you know the things that are buried in
there when you're going through a manual
looking for how to fix this or what this
knob or control means you're not really
going through front to back and kind of
you're just skimming you know you're
just going through getting the
information that you want well guess
what there's some things that stood out
to me that they maybe will stick out to
you as well
if you've seen these things on tractors
the setup whatever it might be or maybe
you can do it on your tractor get some
more versatility or capability or
stability or
anything else that ends in ility out of
it okay
so i promise we're going to keep this
fun we're going to keep it quick we're
going to keep it simple
let's get to it if you haven't done so
yet hit that subscribe button right
underneath the video
make sure you read through the
description as well a lot of good at
links to attachments or accessories
places to get a discount five percent
off discount code gwt
go to goodworkstractors.com as well i
sell tractors i sell attachments all
sorts of good stuff
this is just me the cool things that i
found in the manual if you know
something pretty cool in your manual
because it could be specific just to the
model of traffic that you have
make sure you leave a comment below okay
make sure to check those out as well
it makes it a lot of fun thanks so much
guys okay so this one
is a little unique i have intentionally
got an x series garden tractor
and a one series 10 25 x 738 side by
side right here okay
two different procedures and you know
what this has come up before
uh several times actually when you're
engaging a pto okay so
pay attention because the different
series are going to have different
instructions
so to turn your pto on any john deere
1025r
let's see what it says set engine speed
to 1500 rpms
or less okay lower than that if anything
and then turn your pto on how is that
going to compare to a john deere
x738 garden tractor this is totally
different okay so
after engine has warmed up move the
throttle lever to the
maximum engine speed and then pull your
pto knob and turn it on okay so
totally different depending on what
machine you have what series you have so
never assume it's the same for every
machine always check your manual
good information to know right can
anybody tell me what the difference is
though between one machine versus
another
does it have anything to do with it
being gas versus diesel could that come
into play at all or is there something
else going on
okay courtesy of our 4r series manual
right here okay this is a 4066 tractor
right here but
i think this applies to a lot of
machines it's not just this one this is
where i happen to find it at but
take a look at these front tires okay so
let me just read it really quick here
front tire rolling direction under most
conditions tires should be installed
with a directional arrow pointing in the
direction of travel there's going to be
on most of these tires an arrow that
actually points forward okay so that's
the direction of the tread
however hold on now okay if machine is
mainly used for loader operations
lug direction lugs okay these bad boys
right here
may be reversed to increase tire life
and improve traction while backing out
of dirt piles
intriguing isn't that okay and you know
what i've never seen that emanuel before
and sure that maybe that's just me but
i've had quite a few tractors come
in with the uh the tires mounted in the
opposite position here so you would take
this tire put it on that side and
flip flat one over and put it here okay
but i've had them like that before you
know i've kind of wondered i've kind of
hypothesized actually
thought that before and had folks say
hey your tires are mounted backwards
well
turns out there's actually a legitimate
reason to do so
wheels must be installed so that the
valve stem is facing outwards alright
keep that in mind but
very interesting tidbit of information
there if you're doing a lot of loader
operation
perhaps that's a setup you want to look
into okay so this is one you definitely
want to know before you get into that
situation so pay attention
okay so i want you to pay close
attention to this picture right here can
you see that picture okay
notice how the front wheels are up in
the air the rear ones are here but it
appears to be tipping back
now pay attention you see this chain
right here could be a chain could be a
cart could be a wagon whatever it is but
imagine you're stuck in mud right here
okay you get these
now let me back up if you've ever
watched a fail video of some kind where
you see a tractor online and it is just
tipped right back up over
you know maybe in a a polling contest
even or you know some guys have a
wagon loaded down with brick or wood or
whatever it is and it's just
in swampy muddy areas and things like
that or
it might not even be it might be on a
hard surface like this too
but at a certain point you got to be
very careful if you're stuck and you're
just sitting there spinning because what
could happen
this is right in the manual okay freeing
a mired machine all right
never drive forward okay because if it's
trying to get traction
at a certain point the rear tires could
lock up it could end up flipping the
front end up
and you go tumbling over backwards you
don't want that to happen so
let me read this to you attempting to
free a mired machine can involve
safety hazards such as the mired tractor
tipping rearward
the towing tractor overturning or the
toe chain and tow bar
failing and recoiling from its stretch
condition back your tractor out if it
gets mired down in mud
unhitch any toad implements get them out
of the way dig the mud out from behind
the rear wheels
put boards down there you get the point
i'm just telling this is a big safety
thing
never really even crossed my mind but
it's something you definitely want to
know before you get into that situation
so this one is pretty sweet really
pretty simple and straightforward but i
found it pretty interesting all the same
okay
every six years or six thousand hours
okay so for most of us
never for being honest never never gonna
do it never gonna have to
if coolant is checked annually the
service interval can be extended to six
years six thousand hours
flush and replace at that point now i
don't know about you but i find that to
be pretty incredible and
the same thing can be said for vehicles
you know trucks and and all sorts of
other machines too but these service
intervals are extending further and
further
even regular engine oil changes you know
or every 200 hours
in these so i just find it pretty
incredible they're quite low maintenance
and it's
moving into the lower and lower
maintenance ski there's certain things
you want to do
i want to make sure you know about that
and so while some of these can be
delayed for as long as you possibly want
others like the one i'm going to tell
you about now need to be done on a very
regular basis
like my dad always used to say i'm hard
on you because i love you
okay so i'm not going to stop telling
you about this lube shuttle
grease okay the most important way to
protect your machine why
because it's the one thing they have to
do most often on your machine keep it
greased okay and if you have an
easy way to do that not dealing with one
of those traditional grease guns that
leak all over the place
you can see it right here what's it say
rethink greasing no plunger to pull back
no air gaps no leaking grease no wasted
grease no waste of time
you've got the steel cover on the top
there you undo that you take it off
that's just to
protect it you know and you got grease
tubes here all right you can see there's
no there's no grease leaking out there
there's no mess here at all
you just take it off and you need to
replace it you can even refill these
things if you want but
you get five percent off discount code
gwt i'm telling you greece is your
friend
okay so uh put it on there take care of
it go to the description below in the
video or go to my website you'll see
where you can buy this stuff get five
percent off discount code gwt
okay seriously another important safety
tip here kind of crazy i'm telling you
you just never would think about this
kind of thing we're talking about the
rops okay you got it in a folded
position right here
now what does the manual tell you if you
have it in a folded position say
you need to go underneath the tree
something else like that into a building
whatever else it might be
well it's going to tell you get that
rops back up into the fully upright
position as soon as possible
but while you have it lowered you do not
want to have your seatbelt
on okay do not use a seat belt with the
wraps folded according to your manual
always reference your own manual in case
it tells you something different but
what happens if your rops is in the
fully up position
well as you might imagine you want to
have your seat belt on
if the rops is in the up position okay
so again you want to keep this up just
as much as you possibly can
and if so keep your seatbelt on if you
have it down take it off so
kind of my hypothesis behind that it
doesn't really come out and say that in
the manual here but
if the wraps is up then it's definitely
gonna do what it's designed to do which
is keep it from actually rolling all the
way over it'll tip on its side
and it'll just kind of lay there right
so if you are strapped in here
then there's not really a chance for you
to roll out and get crushed underneath
something here but
if the rops is down then it's not going
to protect it from rolling over right so
if that's the case i think anyways if
you don't have a seat belt on then you
have a better chance of
hopping off or quickly getting out of
the way instead of being crushed by it
as it rolls over
on that note make sure you check out
these safety videos about ballast weight
okay these kinds of things are going to
help keep you grounded keep you in place
duallies wheel spacers liquid ballast
rear ballast all sorts of stuff loading
your loads low
everything you can do to make sure that
kind of situation does not occur
you know just when i thought i knew
everything about trailering a tractor
you'll learn something new right here in
the manual close fuel shut off valve if
your machine is equipped
really you got to turn the fuel off if
you're going to transport your machine
on a trailer
additionally okay i hate this one i hate
even knowing this is in here and i don't
know if i can follow
the rules it says position
machine on trailer so the hood or engine
cover opens from the rear of the trailer
okay that means for most of these
you got to put it on backwards i really
hate backing on
tractors on the trailers i like to drive
them on i like to back them off that's
just what i like doing
what do you guys think you're going to
back them on or drive them forward
okay a couple interesting ones right in
your loader manual pay attention now
we've talked about it before but it
becomes official now that we've located
it in the manual okay so
leveling in reverse say you're grading
out a drive something like that
go golden reverse something like this
maybe a little more maybe a little less
is about the maximum pitch that you want
to have
the max maximum angle on your bucket
there okay to avoid damage to the loader
or bending the bucket cutting edge while
leveling in reverse
position the bucket less than 40 degrees
below level
okay and when possible put it in float
we've talked all about that you guys
know what that is
now let's flip-flop that what about
going forward not in reverse
leveling or scraping and forward okay
what you want to do you want to have
this bucket
almost completely level or just slightly
raised up
to prevent that damage to the bucket
edge there to your cylinders you know to
jamming something up you never want to
go too fast either and again use float
when possible
now you know okay now check this out
this is pretty sweet and i'm going to
tell you
the r4 tires that really common tread
pattern i don't think that that's going
to have this option here
but you get an ag tire like this you see
all these bolts right here how this
inner wheel this plate here is really
separate from the outer wheel of the rim
right here
that gives you up to eight different
rear wheel positions okay that is insane
okay and and think about this
i'm gonna flip over to the other page
here
the narrowest position it shows on here
is 51 inches wide
okay and the widest position it shows on
here is 75 inches wide that is a
two foot difference from from narrowest
to widest position
now it does list an r4 tread pattern
here let me show you
so maybe there is such a thing that
exists and i just don't know about it
i don't know if you can see that or not
but it's right down here you can see the
r4 tread pattern on there but
check out your manual because no matter
what you have
you're going to have at least more than
one position and that's going to really
help some of you with
that lateral stability that you need
which asked about it all the time you
know i put dualies on my little 1025 r
there to help with that stability i've
talked about wheel spacers
all sorts of ways so get yourself that
liquid ballast in here everything you
need to do
in order to get that center of gravity
down low and that without y to just make
your tractor and your machine stable
but some of you you need to have narrow
or wide or different space in there to
get between rows or whatever the case
might be
so pretty cool to know also on your
front wheels as well you're also going
to have
an offset plate so you'll be able to
have a narrower stance or a wider stance
but it does say
note this okay you cannot use the loader
with the wheels in the wide position
okay so i got to be honest i don't like
this one right here but i still found it
interesting because it is the opposite
of what i do
and that is removing material from a
pile okay i know
i know how can there be a problem with
that right but
approach and enter a pile with a level
bucket okay pretty straightforward
if the pile is high remove the top first
okay so you got your big pyramid shape
pile of dirt or stone or mulch or
whatever it is it's telling you if it's
a high pile i don't know how high high
is
but if it's high take the top off first
well first of all
you scoop into a the top of a pile it's
just going to push it off the other end
right
part of the reason i like to go low is
because it gives you something a little
backstop there you know you can push
into it scoop what you need out and pull
it back this is telling you to pull
off the top first and i don't get that
so what do you guys do top bottom
does it matter and to be honest with you
i can't really figure out what the
downside would be just to pull on the
bottom of the pile it's not like we're
talking
it's a stray vertical pile here and if
you pull the bottom out the top is going
to collapse down on you
you know a natural pile of dirt is going
to be kind of a pyramidal shape you know
or a triangular triangular shape with
a tapered side slope going this way
where you're not just going to collapse
everything in on you right
am i forgetting something here am i
missing something what's going on
well those are 10 fascinating pieces of
information i found buried inside our
owner's manuals
what gems have you found that are hidden
share those below make sure you leave a
comment give me a thumbs up give me a
thumbs down
if you haven't done so yet hit that
subscribe button right underneath the
video
make sure you read through the
description as well a lot of useful
links down there places to get five
percent off
with discount code gwt check out the
other videos on the channel and until
next time
stay safe we'll see you soon